Karina is with us in Montgomery hi
Karina welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I have an income problem
I was working at a prestigious law firm
where i temped for three years I was
brought in to work on BP oil spill
claims and when that project wrapped up
I was out of a job now every time I
apply for a job or I go on an interview
soap see that I worked for this
prestigious law firm I'm not there
anymore so there must be something wrong
with me while I was there I got pto I
got bonuses when the project ended I was
given notice and I was also given
severance I can't find a job to save my
life what are you dumb and it's I'm the
paralegal
oh I have a BS in legal studies with the
paralegal certification yeah and you've
talked to all the law firms in
Montgomery not every single one closed I
was told by an attorney friend one that
I'm gonna die with my school loan from
the best thing I can do is walk away
from my mortgage I was told by another
one just last week that the problem is
that there are so many schools in this
area turning out attorneys that the
attorneys are taking paralegal jobs and
he even introduced me to his own
assistant who is an attorney who's
passed the bar and he's paying him $10
an hour I can't find a job
I tried pizza delivery that does not
work out I've tried how old are you 55
oh my beater is more than 20 years old
I've cycled
unemployment I'm about to get food
stamps I have no income and you're
single I'm single okay mm-hmm no kids
I'm an empty nester it's just me my
mortgage is $550 and I can't pay my
mortgage well I just scary don't blame
me for being scared to understand I
don't know how to address the paralegal
part of this equation I I'll do anything
I got that I got that I'm hearing where
you are you're desperate and you start
anywhere and go from there right so I
just I go to I always go back to really
primitive stuff like you said you know
you're delivering pizzas are over or
whatever but you're driving a beater and
that's kind of thing I mean I go back to
you know people make $25 an hour
cleaning houses and you can clean a
house and you just got to find somebody
let you do it and then find two more to
let you do it then three more to let you
do it and if you show up on time and
you're honest and don't steal their
stuff and you clean their house and
you're good at cleaning and you're a
pleasant person don't stand around talk
all day you get your work done then you
know you're gonna get a bunch of houses
clean but that's not alternately our
long-term goal but at least that would
get the wolf away from the door maybe
I'm just dreaming up something here off
the top of my head to try to get you
something to do for a little bit of
money I offered to work for free for my
attorney just so I could get the type of
experience that attorneys seem to lunch
not even free yeah I'm not buying that I
mean I get that this one guy hired an
attorney for $10 an hour who was
desperate I got that it could be that
there's no market for paralegals I will
tell you in general
that the economy the unemployment rate
is the lowest it's ever been in in
recent memory in general the economy is
white-hot I mean like for instance in
our area in Nashville just a few hours
north of you we have a labor shortage
here in terms of finding people to work
there's there's there's you know
employment signs on every door when you
walk up to a restaurant or a retail
situation or anything like that and so I
I'm kind of shocked that Montgomery
isn't is dead I don't think it is so it
might be I mean maybe you maybe need to
move cities I don't know but I'm happy
to do that yeah if you could find
something don't so I may have you seen
paralegal hirings in other markets I've
seen more ads for Birmingham I'll go
anywhere that's her house worse it might
be worth 40 45 50 you know you know how
much do on it aisle 50 oh no you owe
more on it than it's worth
yes yes I've been in this house for 50
15 years our neighborhood has gone
section 8 and there are shootings here
regularly nobody wants to be here okay
now that may be why you were getting the
advice to walk away from the mortgage
but for $500 a month you got a place to
live for today yes can are you a member
of a good local church yeah okay go sit
down with your pastor and and ask him if
he knows business people in the
congregation that are hiring and and ask
him ask him also to mentor you on
interviewing skills and appearance if
there's anything you're doing
there to be blunt with you okay like
absolutely yeah like you need to you
need to cut your hair or you need to get
a different suit of clothes or whatever
right I don't know I have no idea but I
mean appearance and you know just
talking to you you're scared but you're
articulate and intelligent I don't know
why you couldn't carry an interview as
far as those skills go your
interpersonal skills it doesn't sound
like that that's killing your interview
I mean you're not calling me up you know
you know you're not calling me up with
that kind of a problem and you know and
we know you've got a level of intellect
because you don't get the paralegal
school if you don't it's you know so but
you know you would make an excellent
personal assistant for an executive as
an example because you know how to write
like business letters you know you've
worked on that kind of thing so that
would be an example of something that
you could move into I don't have any
magic pills here but I'm anything from
cleaning houses to movin cities to
talking to your pastor those are the
three things that pop into my head to
get you something going where you're not
just completely scared and overwhelmed
and lost hope just a little bit of money
changes your whole situation really fast
that's the good news
this is the Dave Ramsey show